Speaker 1: Earlier this week, I told you that
Rudy Giuliani and John Eastman, two former
Donald Trump lawyers and Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham, have all been subpoenaed by
a court in the state of Georgia. And it's become
very common for Republicans to ignore subpoenas
from Congress to appear before the January six
committee. But ignoring a subpoena from a court
is a very different thing. Well, we've now
heard from Republican Senator Lindsey Graham.
He says he's not going to cooperate with the
Georgia Trump election probe. Now, importantly,
some of you wrote to me and said, how can Lindsey
get away with this? This isn't he going to be
thrown in jail for contempt of court? Understand,
Lindsey is not saying he's going to ignore it.
He's saying he's going to fight it. He's going to
try to fight the subpoena. Senator Lindsey Graham
reports. Reuters will not comply with a subpoena
issued by a grand jury in Georgia investigating
Trump's attempts to overturn the results of the
2020 elections. Quote Senator Graham plans to go
to court to challenge the subpoena and expects to
prevail, said, I guess, two of his attorneys. They
say Graham was well within his rights to discuss
with state officials the processes and procedures
around administering elections. What they're
referring to is that Graham called and you know,
it was very clear he was trying to strong
arm Georgia into flipping the results.
But what they're calling it is
a discussion about procedures.
Very benign way to refer to it. The grand jury
also subpoenaed Rudy Giuliani and others. The
grand jury was selected in May to look at
evidence in a probe launched after Trump
was recorded on a phone call pressuring
state officials to overturn the results.
Graham's attorney said in the statement that
the senator was being called simply as a witness
in what they call a fishing expedition. Any
information from an interview or a deposition with
Senator Graham would immediately be shared with
the January six committee. They don't like that.
And he is going to try to fight the subpoena. Now,
if he tries to fight the subpoena and loses and a
court says you have to respond to the subpoena,
and he doesn't. He would then be in contempt of
court. That is not where we are right now. If
the court decides he must comply and he doesn't,
it will become a legal issue for him. Unlikely.
I have to tell you that he will end up arrested
because he's not again, he's not a subject or
a target of the investigation. He's merely a
witness. He still could be held in contempt.
He could face daily fines. If he ignores it,
it's not likely that he's going to be imprisoned.
And if he still didn't pay the fines that are
assigned to him for ignoring the subpoena,
then his assets could be seized. But it is
very unlikely that Lindsey is actually going to
get himself arrested. That's where we are right
now. Of course, it would be great if everybody
just complied and they could tell us everything
we need to know. And it would be very clear that
everybody is innocent, nobody did anything wrong,
and then we could just all move on with our lives.
But instead they are obstructing and impeding and
trying to get in the way of these investigations
at every turn. I will remind you, my opinion
remains that it is more likely that if there are
going to be big time charges even against Trump,
which I don't think is particularly likely, but
if it's going to happen, I believe it's far more
likely to come from the Georgia investigation
than from the January six investigation. And I've
given the reasons why already, and that's where my
mind remains. Obviously, if they don't get people
to comply with subpoenas, it will be much more
difficult to build these cases. We will have more
on all of these stories on The David Pakman Show
Instagram, which can be found at David Pakman show